bonjour à toutes et à tous ici arcoroc
j'espère que vous allez très bien
aujourd'hui on va parler de strangers
things notamment sa fin qui fait de
nombreux débats et voilà on se retrouve
sur une vidéo un peu chill donc j'espère
que ça vous plaira on va parler ensemble
tranquillement n'hésitez pas à réagir
vous dans les commentaires
ce que vous avez pensé de la série y
voter au riz etc et d'ailleurs je l'
annonce il y aura 1 3 théorie un bon
gros trois théories sa mère sur
strangers singh saison 3 enfin surtout
strangers in saison 4 ont déjà je vais
pas trop revenir je pense sur mon trois
théories que j'avais fait sur strangers
things bien qui vous ai énormément plu
mais
j'ai eu faux sur beaucoup beaucoup de
choses et plein de petits détails sur
lequel j'avais bon genre de revers le
futur et cetera mais bon bref ça n'a pas
d'importance je suis je regrette pas du
tout trois théories je suis content de
ce que j'ai produit
je trouve que j'ai amené matière à
réfléchir enfin bref passons directement
au vif du sujet cette saison était
vraiment incroyable je suis vraiment un
fan de strangers singh à chaque fois
j'hésite je me dis wow a game of thrones
c'est mieux non strangers in c'est mieux
bref les deux se confrontent je suis
vraiment un énorme fan est là cette
saison je la trouve encore meilleur que
les deux premières donc c'est là le
premier choc que j'ai eu avec le 3 0 que
j'avais fait c'est que je restais
énormément sur la pop culture et les
jeux vidéos les films etc
parce que c'est avait il y avait
toujours un rapport dans les deux
premières saisons
aujourd'hui voilà les personnages on
grandit on est clairement vraiment dans
du très sérieux on s'approche de la fin
car normalement il ya quatre saisons
il hésitait à en faire une cinquième
mais normalement la base c'était quatre
saisons donc normalement la prochaine
sera la dernière
et du coup c'est normal qu'on rentre
dans du concret vraiment du sérieux et
notamment avec le conflit soviétique
soit la guerre froide carrément entre
les américains et les russes et
franchement ça a ajouté un truc qui
était vraiment ouf j'ai vraiment aimé
bien qu'il ait toujours ce petit côté
enfantin ce petit côté fun fantaisie et
cetera
là on est vraiment dans quelque chose
d'un peu plus sérieux d'un peu plus
dangereux et franchement c'était j'ai
trouvé cette ce risque en quelque sorte
vraiment pas mal je trouve vraiment la
saison encore plus kiffante il ya aussi
du fait qu'on connaisse beaucoup déjà
les personnages depuis maintenant trois
saisons ce qui accentue également ce
côté dangereux ce côté très sérieux ce
côté
vraiment là beaucoup plus effrayant là
on rentre plus dans les codes de
l'horreur je trouve que les deux
premiers où c'était plus franchement du
stress car moi personnellement j'avoue
les films d'horreur ça me fait pas grand
chose c'est pas quelque chose qui
m'intéresse qui maillent peu ou autre et
là on n'y avait plus de décote d'horreur
donc après j'avais pas forcément peur un
même la lumière est un tout autre
mais il y avait beaucoup plus de gore et
la part quand c'était un petit peu
dérangeant j'avoue ça le gore ça
m'écoeure jeu là vous je me suis demandé
justement savait pas une inspiration par
rapport au film the thing ou the thing
je me souviens plus exactement pour ceux
qui connaissent ou en gros une sorte de
virus extraterrestre qui s'abat sur un
lieu avec de la neige je me souviens
plus ça fait très longtemps que j'ai vu
mais c'est un film qui m'a beaucoup
marqué et en gros les humains vont
chauffer ce virus et ils viennent mais
totalement désarticulé horriblement
moche et gore et je me sens que ça
m'avait marqué car je n'ai vu quand
j'étais genre pré ado j'avais 12 ans
environ 13 ans et ça m'avait mais
traumatisé tellement c'était dégueulasse
et j'ai trouvé qu'on retrouvait une
certaine patte de sa notamment avec le
le mind flyers lac est composé de bouts
d'os et séraphin dégueu mais du coup ça
rajoute est un côté vraiment dangereux
et très sérieux à la chose et là il y
avait vraiment beaucoup de morts comparé
aux deux premières saisons où la
première saison il y avait que 1 mort
fin qu'un mort peut dire mort importante
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des soldats ou
autres qui mourrait ou autre mais voilà
vous comprenez l'idée là il ya vraiment
beaucoup d'innocents plutôt d'innocents
qui meurt et c'est savoir ajoute
vraiment à côté ça j'aimerais
personnellement aussi revenir sur billy
quart
effectivement la mort de billy m'a fait
vraiment quelque chose c'est vraiment un
regret qu'ils soient morts car billy
c'était vraiment au final le personnage
qui a subi sa vie en fait toute sa vie
ça a été que galère et c'est le fait
qu'ils qu'il meure en pseudo héros du
coup car il a fait énormément de mal
semble vouloir étant possédé par le my
fire mais a tenté de sauver les autres
est du coup donné sa vie c'est ça rend
encore la chose encore plus tragique car
au final billy n'était pas quelqu'un de
mauvais du tout mais c'est juste que il
a eu un parcours de vie très difficiles
et ça fait vraiment ch et qu'ils doivent
mourir qu'il doit mourir pardon si jeune
et dans de telles circonstances
alors que il aurait pu rattraper toute
sa vie du coup sa vie s'est résumée à
une galère et du coup ça m'a fait
quelque chose personnellement du coup la
symbolique est très forte et j'ai
vraiment aimé sa mort entre guillemets
bien que ce soit à regret mais c'est un
regret positif voilà c'est pas un défaut
de la série du tout c'est juste que
c'est triste c'est juste ça donc il ya
vraiment plein de choses abordé plein de
choses qui sont encore floues et boire
parler parce qu'il y aura notamment le
trois théories qui va qui va arriver
très prochainement
ça va être une grosse vidéo j'espère que
vous serez au rendez vous on va passer
directement à la fin je pense et ah oui
du coup sachez que je lis ça en ce
moment et ça va vraiment m'aider à
parfaire mes connaissances stranger
things et vous proposer une vidéo archi
complète donc c'est cool
alors oui là on va rentrer un petit peu
dans du débat et je pense que vous allez
pas trop aimer ce que je vais vous dire
etc
on va parler du coût de la mort de
hopper et ça fait vraiment ch et qu'il
soit mort mais pour moi c'est le cas il
est mort effectivement la menace n'est
pas terminée c'est évident
le mann flyers reviendra parce qu'il
reste une dernière saison est une saison
un peu ultime
et voilà donc la scène de fin on est
chez les russes à kamtchaka du coup j'ai
commencé à faire des recherches et où on
est à kamtchaka donc sais c'est pas si
loin que ça au final de hawkins d'après
ce qu'on peut voir enfin j'ai regardé un
peu sur google maps et où c'est pas si
loin que ça même si c'est quand même une
trotte un jeu vous le cache pas mais ce
n'est pas vraiment si si loin qu'on le
pense
et du coup on tombe chez les soviétiques
qui dans une base secrète sont en train
de s'occuper de démo corps gonds et
cetera de les nourrir et toutes les
apprivoiser moi je pense et il donne un
russe du coup il y avait un américain
par aman dans une présent et il donne du
coup un russe à manger au démon gorgon
bien ça c'est ce que nous savons
beaucoup d'entre vous pensent que c'est
aux peurs du coût qui serait l'américain
enfermé dans la prison
malheureusement j'avoue que je ne pense
pas trop voilà c'est aux peurs pour moi
il est mort et c'est à raison fait une
scène de ouf avec son dernier texte son
message qui voulait attribuer à elf je
dirais lf parce que j arrive jamais à
comprendre comme ils le disent en
anglais elle
mais sauf que pour moi elle c'est
l'enfer enfin bref je m'égare je dirais
lf dont il ya toute une symbolique très
importante autour de hopper et c'est
vrai c'est inimaginable pour moi que
hopper ne fasse plus partie de strangers
things qui soit définitivement mort et
tout pour la suite
et c'est comme ça j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est justement les frères de firth
inspirait beaucoup de harry potter
notamment pour le man flyers et c'est
pareil qu'on peut comparer aux cas de
dumbledore en fait
alors attention spoiler alert pour harry
potter ben oui doubled aux rumeurs je le
voyais pas du tout partir à un moment
moi je n'avais pas lu les livres et
c'est clair que d'imaginer la suite
centre de mulder c'est compliqué c'est
un petit peu la même avec hopper hopper
c'est très dur d'imaginer la suite et
pour moi il est bel et bien mort déjà
dans comment s'est montrée dans le
cinéma on va dire en général
la machine va exploser
on ne monte pas au peur parce qu'on est
tellement attaché au personnage ce
serait horrible de le voir exploser en
mille morceaux
mais ajustements 4 se douchent
scientifiques qui sont au même endroit
au même moment et qui du coup se font
exploser en bouillie par la machine qui
explose justement et c'est pour bien
signifier que voilà toute personne à
côté de la machine va exploser et c'est
le cas avec hopper je pense alors il ya
une sorte de petit fort accord je lave
ou dans la série parce que du coup j'ai
bien regardé la scène parce que vous
étiez tellement en parler et à m'envoyer
des messages privés là dessus c'est vrai
que hopper n'est plus vraiment à côté de
la machine au moment où elle va exploser
mais ce pas ce genre une fraction de
seconde avant que au moment où joyce
active la machine et où elle explose
hopper est vraiment mort en se
sacrifiant c'est pour moi c'est obligé
en fait et ce n'est pas lui du cou qui
est dans la prison il ya même quasiment
plus de russes dans la base à ce moment
précis je sais pas je pour moi ce n'est
pas où peur et je suis désolé pour pour
ceux qui y croyaient en revanche s'il ya
d'autres américains et moi j'ai
notamment deux en tête qui pourrait
correspondre cette histoire d'américains
dans la prison c'est clair que c'est un
détail qui est souligné
donc c'est fait exprès si ce détail
souligner c'est que c'est important et
notamment aussi par rapport aux démos
gorgon qui est présent donc ça veut dire
qu'il ya toujours un portail dit ouvert
à cet endroit car du coup l'autre
endroit
stark out le portail fermé du coup à
empêcher la connexion donc ça veut dire
que
un périmètre on va dire ils peuvent pas
trop s'éloigner autant que ça du coup et
qu'il faut d'autres portails pour créer
d'autres connexions et faire venir etc
enfin vous m'avez compris donc si le
lundi ce de l'américain est soulignée et
qu'en plus à des démos gorgon ça veut
dire que cette personne pour moi connais
forcément toute l'histoire du man flyers
des démos gorgon des mots dog et c'est
pourquoi cela
tout simplement car on n'aurait pas
vraiment d'histoire en fait nous sommes
dans une base russe
vraiment très bien isolées où ils sont
en train pour moi d'apprivoiser des
démos corps gonds et qui du coup
l'info ne se transmettra pas en fait il
faut que pour la saison 4 l'info se
transmettent jusqu'à hawkins au moins et
enfin bref je suis incapable de vous
dire ce qui va se passer dans la saison
4 pour le moment mais c'est juste par
logique en fait il faut qu' au moins une
personne qui sache donc cet américain
normalement saurai ce qui se passe dans
cette base ce serait vraiment le seul et
il trouverait un moyen de s'échapper et
du coup de revenir en amérique pour
alerter justement les des personnes
compétentes qui seraient au courant de
ce qui se passe donc cet américain est
forcément quelqu'un un peu de connu pour
nous alors après je ne cache pas que ça
peut être un nouveau personnage qui va
arriver dans la série on ne sait pas ce
serait tout à fait louable vraiment mais
il faut qu'ils aient un bac g quand même
par rapport aux démos grands comptes et
moi j'ai vraiment pour le moment alors
après je vais y réfléchir un peu plus de
mon côté mais j'ai vraiment deux idées
en tête
par rapport à ça le premier pour moi
serait baumann ce que j'ai bien regardé
dans la série tout c'est la première
chose qui m'a fait tilt et baumann sort
avec joyce
mais il disparaît tout d'un coup enfin
c'est pas qui disparaît tout d'un coup
il ya les livres de trois mois mais on
sait pas du tout ce que devient baumann
portant baumann devient double quand
même assez important là dans cette
saison 2 par rapport
dans cette saison 3 pardon par rapport à
la saison 2 et la saison une chez même
plus s'il y était mais je crois même pas
donc pour moi de bowman
il y aurait un rapport surtout que
il a été vu avec alexis qu'il parle
russe et qu'il est rentré incognito dans
la base et c'est beaucoup de russes se
sont échappés et il est possible qu'ils
aient kidnappé quelqu'un au même moment
donc il est possible pour moi que ce
soit baumann et franchement ce serait
très crédible je pense malgré que bowman
n'ai jamais vu de démo borgo ou my mind
flyers etc
je pense qu'il comprendrait très vite ce
qui se passe mais il ne faut pas oublier
qu'ils aient une ellipse de trois mois
et ça ça casse vraiment tout enfin ça
c'est pas que ça casse vraiment tout
mais c'est que c'est très difficile du
coup de déterminer ce qui s'est vraiment
passé durant ces trois mois et que ça
peut être n'importe qui en fait ça peut
être même joyce pendant son déménagement
mais bon je ne pense pas parce que ses
marques et l'américain donc c'est je
pense que ça doit être un homme
franchement je pense que c'est un homme
et je joue ici la ménage beaucoup de
mincir et donc je pense pas que ce ne
soit l du tout mais enfin vous comprenez
l'idée quoi ça peut être aussi johnattan
pourquoi pas que s'est fait kidnapper ça
peut être n'importe qui mon autre idée
et c'est là où vous allez me dire mais
what the fuck qu'est ce tu nous raconter
vraiment un conte et tous aux mêmes pas
le dire parce que vous avez vous [ __ ]
de ma gueule
ce serait le docteur brennan alors après
je vous avoue je n'ai pas encore fini le
livre etc
bon après ça le livre c'est ça se passe
avant la série mais il est vrai que pour
moi ben renner est tellement important
dans la série
c'est même pour ça que je pense qu'ils
ont fait un livre dédié à lui car il est
hyper important et brenner pourrait
avoir pactisé avec les russes il se
pourrait que ce dernier ait appris enfin
et pai a primé survécu aux démos gorgon
pour vous ou peur hopper a failli
survivre a pu survivre même et se faire
kidnapper chez les russes il se peut
qu'un docteur brenner pareil se fassent
kidnapper et qu'il est même pactisé avec
les russes par la suite on n'en sait
trop rien et voilà brenner a vraiment
une connaissance énorme
et là il aurait moyen d'en plus rouvrir
un autre portail faire revenir apporter
toutes ses connaissances et ça intéresse
de ouf les russes notamment par rapport
à hopkins
donc voilà c'est qu'une idée comme ça
mais je pense que
ça reste légitime mais le plus probable
pour moi ce serait vraiment baumann
après il est possible qu'il y ait aussi
le maire j'ai pensé oh mais aussi de
larry car voilà larry a fait des pactes
un peu avec les russes s'est fait
arrêter par les flics
il est possible qu'ils se soient fait
kidnapper qui s'est fait emmener et que
lui ne sache pas vraiment ce qui se
passe mais voilà c'est y qui réussissent
à s'échapper on ne sait pas comment ou
autre mais il est possible que ce soit
la ri aussi moi je pense un cg mais des
hypothèses comme ça je vous fais un
petit peu mon trois théories l'a déjà
franchement cette scène de fin elle
applique vraiment beaucoup de choses car
ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi
effectivement un développement des
portails en quelque sorte
il est possible que le portail qui soit
ouvert à kamtchaka du coup pour faire
venir un démon gorgon qu'il est possible
qu'ils aient plusieurs portails dans le
monde sans qu'on le sache et qu'il y ait
un rapport avec aussi les enfants pour
la saison 4
après j'avoue je n'ai pas lu tout genre
j'ai lu que le premier chapitre pour le
moment mais il est possible qu'on voit
plusieurs enfants etc
enfin bref me spoil est pas le livre
j'ai pas encore tout lu j'ai peut-être
des bêtises mais il ya énormément de
choses qui sont possibles pour la saison
4 c'est justement pour ça qu'on va
théorisé donc toutes ses dimensions
russe peut-être vraiment très très
intéressante car j'ai commencé un peu à
me restera me renseigner et même par
rapport à mes cours d'histoire il ya
plein de choses qu'on sait déjà mais du
coup il est possible que la fin de la
série se passe quelques années plus tard
pour justement terminé en beauté avec
notamment la guerre froide
pourquoi pas genre en 91 ou live du coup
il aurait bien grandi mais on perdrait
quand même le charme de la série où ce
sont en général des des enfants pré ados
et c'est donc le plus logique c'est que
ça se passerait en 1986 si la
multiplication des portails c'est ce qui
est possible il se peut qu'ils aient
d'autres portails en russie et notamment
en ukraine et en 1986 il ya
quelque chose d'énorme qui se passe dans
l'histoire c'est tchernobyl
il est possible qui est un rapport dans
la série avec tchernobyl admettons que
tchernobyl soit dû au retour du mind
flyers mais en ukraine ou en ou
peut-être en russie va kamtchaka plein
de choses sont possibles et le fact
intéressant avec les russes je pense
c'est que au début en fait on croit que
au début de la scène de fin nous on
croit qu'on efface un démo dogues cary
leahey ce 4 4 en train de marcher puis
tout d'un coup il se lève et du coup là
on comprend qu'on efface un démo gorgon
ce n'est pas fait par hasard
évidemment si on croit concernées 1 face
à des mots dogues de démo dogues c'est
la phase la moins évolué en quelque
sorte des créatures de l'opci down mais
là nous sommes face du coup un démo
gorgon à notre plus grande surprise donc
ça veut dire que ça fait un moment qu'il
est présent et qu'ils l'ont plutôt
développer etc
il se pourrait que les russes fassent
comme avait fait dustin dans la saison 2
avec d'artagnan je crois qu'il avait
appelé comme ça d'artagnan et qu'il les
apprivoise en fait en leur donnant des
prisonniers d voilà des ennemis de
guerre ou autre il se pourrait que les
russes et said d'apprivoiser les
monstres de l'ops aydan notamment des
démos gorgon et c'est ça se retournera
forcément contre eux mais qu'il y ait un
truc avec eux qu'ils essayent d'en
développer plusieurs comme une petite
armée peut-être un truc du genre
jusqu'au moment où le mind flyers
apparaîtra et du coup il s'il apparaîtra
à kamtchaka et c'est peu prévisible mais
du coup c'est sûr les russes les
apprivoise pour ensuite essayer de les
utiliser
je pense sincèrement mais la chose
intéressante c'est que du coup par
rapport à la saison 2 il y avait un
épisode qui avait été vraiment - mx
d'habitude c'est quand elle fait du coup
par à new york pour retrouver et cali et
caetera et on sortait dawkins du coup
savait pas vraiment plu est là pour ces
dernières saisons nous sommes carrément
en russie dans une base secrète
ça va amener que du coup le my fire va
se développer là bas très certainement
et à part être là bas du cou va y avoir
beaucoup de séquences en russie et je me
demande vraiment le risque qu'ils vont
prendre car du coup on va sortir de
hawkins même jaune est sorti de hawkins
à voir ce que ça fera mais je suis
curieux de voir ce que ça donnera
bref je pense avoir dit pas mal de
choses il est clair qu'elle even
retrouvera ses pouvoirs qu'il y aurait
de nouveau personnage très intéressant
notamment le retour de cali je pense est
peut-être voir d'autres enfants je ne
cache pas que hopper vous avez le droit
d'y croire
après ce n'est que mon avis hein mais je
pense vraiment que hopper est mort et
qu'il va falloir faire sans
bref je n'ai pas grand chose à rajouter
plus j'espère sincèrement que ma vidéo
vous aura plu c'était vraiment une
petite vidéo à coeur ouvert où je vous
parle de strangers inc de ce qui m'a plu
et tous et et sa suite on reparlera de
tout ça dans un bon gros trois théories
je vous en ai déjà dévoilé pas mal mais
je vais affiner mes recherches lire le
livre et tout donc ça va être une très
bonne vidéo
franchement ça va être une grosse vidéo
ça va sortir très bientôt je pense la
semaine prochaine un truc du genre
et puis écouter bas n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit pouce bleus à vous
abonner me soutenir via utile me suivent
sur instagram et cetera 7 et argo rock
et écouté que le lionheart soit avec
vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]